thank you very much prya and Ty for
inviting me to this very interesting
workshop and I I might not be the most
obvious contributor to workshop on
inference so I'm a physicist by training
but I've spent last decade assessing
science and communicating science as in
translating physics to physicists and to
other
scientists um and this talk is not about
cation so it's quite a change of gear
from what you heard earlier it's also
shorter talk so I hope like we can
discuss a bit at the end so I'll talk
about the scientific method and the
scientific
discourse and I'd like to start with the
four or like maybe five paradigms of
science you might or might not have
heard about they were introduced by a
computer scientist Jim Gray who's also
uh got a touring award and in 2007 he
gave a talk where um he he said like
there three and now four paradigms of
Science and these are have appeared in
historical order like empirical that's
how science first was um by description
of natural observations and description
of natural phenomena and in the next
paradig theoretical we starting using
models and
generalizations uh the third Paradigm is
computational with the rise of of
computers where scientists have started
to simulate complex
phenomena and what this is quite obvious
but what Jim Gray said the uh the fourth
Paradigm of science is data exploration
which brings together Theory experiment
and
simulation and is is a different way of
doing different scientific method and he
talked Al about it in as I said in um uh
he gave a talk in 2007 and months later
he disappeared at Sea so he never lived
to to see actually that he was quite
right and we've seen uh quite a lot of
development and actually we see a fifth
Paradigm emerging and I'll talk about
that uh but like despite Jim greo being
able to explore his ideas further his
collaborators put together a book based
on his idea does in contributed essays
that is called the force Paradigm of
Science and was published in 2009 and is
freely available on the internet
so what does this have to do with
inference at all well as we've gone
through historically through these
different paradigms of science which
actually all coexist today also the the
way inference Works has changed like
there's no oneto one correspondence of
paradigms of inference I'm no claiming
that but we can say that it started with
induction deduction and we moved towards
statistical types of inference in the
age of computational and data
exploration and what I claim is that now
in the fifth Paradigm of science we see
things like simulation based inference I
talk a bit more about that I'm no expert
in simulation based inference so don't
Grim me on that but uh we'll discuss it
in a moment so I'll I'll go a bit
now into each Paradigm and show you how
the scientific discourse look like in
each of these paradigms so back to the
basics is the first Paradigm of direct
observations of natural phenomena we can
see the scientific discourse and here
I'm taking a bit narrow view of the
scientific discourse is mainly
scientific paper but it's true in more
more broadly so here's an example Edmund
hel in
1714 had seen a solar eclipse describes
it in a paper for the Royal
Society yeah in the second paradig start
building theoretical models to explain
empirical observations and we have
equations that are solved analytically
and an example of that is Max Maxwell's
equations
1864 this is the paper where he
describes them so again we don't see a
lot of change in the scientific
discourse so far but um it's clear like
science scientific method itself is
evolving in the third Paradigm we have
computers and we can solve complex
mathematical models by numerical
simulations so and this is a nice
example a paper I particularly like this
is the Metropolis
algorithm and it's interesting for
several reasons so it's arguably the the
earliest um computational physics paper
ever published
and it's it describes what is known as
Metropolis algorithm but actually
Metropolis himself didn't contribute
much to this paper more he was the one
who provided time on the computer on
Maniac uh the people who actually did
the work were um Ariana and Marshall
Rosenberg held by austa and edwarda and
what tells us this again if you just
look at the paper it's actually quite
modern
uh despite being from
1953 but what we already noticed here
they are more contributors to this paper
and they all have done different things
um and this will become even more so in
the first Paradigm of science where
Discovery is enabled by the exploration
of massive data sets and the example I
chose here is the discovery of the higs
boson so why is it interesting is this
was like a great achievement not only
technically from an experimental point
of view but also from the data analysis
point of view and already
by 2012 had been used they had used lots
of machine learning to do the data
analysis and here like already we're
talking about thousands of authors
involved in um in this paper so Jim Gray
thought that this data exploration was
considerably distinct from the previous
computational paradigm
to deserve its own you know separate um
naming how about the fifths well this
this remains to be defined but there are
lots of ideas floating around um so for
example this is from
2019 um maybe computers will decide
objectively which experiments yield the
biggest gain in our knowledge and they
would drive the experimental
investigations other ideas said that
that maybe computerss will be robust
emulators to replace traditional
numerical simulation methods this is a
STS taken uh by Christopher Bishop who's
at Microsoft research and actually say
like the fourth Paradigm of science
which was published by Microsoft
research so they like this idea very
much uh and then we wrote in a bit more
dramatic departure from these ideas we
wrote last year in an editorial that
maybe machines will no longer be just
tools but they'll be equal Partners in
the scientific
exploration and they will gain some
scientific understanding that we share
with human peers and that's a bit more
radical but still like all these ideas
are kindered and now I mentioned um I
mentioned simulation based inference and
this is also expected to have a profound
impact on science and it's actually
related to the idea of robust
stimulators because uh this is how the
likelihood uh they get the likelihood in
simulation based inference so all these
ideas have something in common AI will
play a very important Ro how we don't
know yet and how will the scientific
discourse change in this fifth Paradigm
again we don't
know but has the scientific discourse
changed at all well I say no because
we're still stuck in the first three
paradigms and again I I want to make it
clear that by scientific discourse I
take the narrower view of scientific
writing as a way to convey ideas and
observations in a persuasive way to your
scientific peers yeah this is this is
what I understand here by scientific
discourse and why hasn't it changed at
all so you see like methodology has
evolved we use different methodologies
at this stage but the discourse hasn't
is it the format or is the
audience and I will give the I will
explore this two and I'll give reason
why it is and a reason why it shouldn't
be
so so we're actually stuck in print in
terms of format and this is not this
should not be surprising actually
because in the long history of
scientific publishing online has been
here for a very short time so the first
journals appear in 1665 five and
actually the philosophical transactions
are still published
today like journals like Nature and
Science came much later and first online
journals actually came in the um late
80s and beginning of the '90s and the
preprint started the archive started
around the same time and so these are
like New Kids on the Block in the
history of scientific publishing and
nature digitized its full archive in
2008 and as of 2007 I don't know if they
they finished it but Royal Society was
still digitizing its full archive back
to
1665 so we don't have everything online
yet
and purely online only journals have
only come very very recently but even
for online only journals they they still
stuck in print even though they've never
been
printed think of the PDF format that any
online Journal still has think of the
table of contents that signifies an
issue and if you're in the uh trade of
publishing a journal like I am you'll
encounter a lot of very
frustrating uh restrictions that have
like historical things like about how
you lay out things how you actually
physically print and physically bind an
issue which of course have no sense in
this age but they still there um and for
like some 10 years now people have been
talking about the article of the
future uh a lot of thought has been put
into this and there' have been
experiments but in the end like we still
have the same format as
before but I think we do need to change
because the scientific narrative these
day is a very complex one and it's very
hard to distill in the traditional print
bound format like today a scientific
article is not like a highly example
like I've seen an eclipse and I'll write
down what I've seen increasingly relies
on lots of code and lots of data Maybe
huge amounts of data that have gone
through rounds and rounds of processing
of instruments that are complicated in
themselves and the parameters they run
on they're very important to describe
the methods and the protocols we need to
know about that and of course the main
story also relies on a large Corpus of
knowledge that is found in the
bibliography and we see that these
bibliographies go longer and longer and
longer as time goes so everything has
all these elements have to come together
and be distilled in a what is
essentially a print format obviously
that's not possible how about the
audiences well different disciplines
have very different cultures with their
own jargon and their own custom and it's
fair to say uh without offending anyone
that some disciplines are more modern
than others and you see some disciplines
are interesting in evolving and changing
things also because they deal maybe with
more non-traditional products like data
or code While others are not and what
we've seen there's a lot of resistance
in accepting to change the scientific
discourse by exploring new article
format and experimenting with different
narratives this has to do with tradition
and
also the fact that we tend to give to
associate rigor and Authority with
traditionally established formats
because if we try to present the
scientific discourse in a new form it
will simply not be seen as authorative
and
trustworthy but at the same time who's
reading this who's benefiting from the
scientific discourse and I really really
like this infographic mind you this is
almost 10 years old so what it shows is
a mountain of paper so if you were to
print the first page of every single
item that is indexed in web of Science
and stuck it up in 10 years ago you
would have got a pile as high as Mount
Kilimanjaro I'm curious how high this
pile has gone up now but like my
colleagues at nature they promised that
they will redo this infographic so
hopefully we'll see that next year but
of this huge huge pile only the very
very very tiny top is what okay if you
consider citations as a proxy of how
much the paper was read maybe it's not a
good proxy but how much this paper is
known it still gives a very
sad view of like how much is actually
read of this huge huge mountain of
knowledge and it's true now that the
scientific literature is increasingly
specialized like even for people from
the same discipline it's really hard to
understand what is going on let Al learn
like if you're trying to read from other
disciplines so we're getting narrower
and narrower and we understand less and
less and we have less and less time of
reading this whole knowledge that is out
there and this literature we're
producing the scientific discourse we're
producing is increasingly R by machines
rather than human beings
um so what what point am I trying to
make scientific method has evolved has
become more complex and we're moving
towards a new paradigm where AI in
whatever form it will play an important
role but the scientific discourse itself
has not evolved beyond the first three
paradigms and I think that it's very
important now that as we move to toward
the fifth Paradigm to try to find new
ways new forms of scientific writing
scientific discourse that are more
representative of the scientific method
the complex narratives we're trying to
convey and actually the
audiences because who we are we writing
for and I think we need to adapt the
scientific discourse to the needs of the
21st century
scientist and I also think and I
experienced this a lot trying
to publish new new forms of narratives I
got a lot of push back so I want to say
like let's be open-minded the scientific
discourse is not fixed like the
scientific methods is not fixed it's
evolving so so should the scientific
discourse now before I end I I want to
make my to be my own Devil's Advocate
and preempt question that you might have
and say okay like if nobody's reading
only like machines are reading why
should we care about the scientific
discourse at all yeah and actually I
think the scientific discourse will
remain important as long as we human
beings are interested in science because
this is how we share the science we
share the new ideas and we share the
understanding we have gained and a year
ago we published this very interesting
perspective called on scientific
understanding with artificial
intelligence was a bit of a strange type
of review so the authors came up used
like a definition of scientific
understanding from the philosophy of
science maybe not or people agree with
that but they use this definition as an
umbrella term to collect scattered
literature about how computers can help
us achieve understanding scientific
understanding and they use that to make
a survey of what has been done and then
they finished like with the discussion
where they said like we could we propose
a test for scientific understanding
which is basically whether a human
teacher or computer teacher is better at
uh explaining to a student a scientific
concept and you see where this comes
it's a sort of touring test um and fine
I mean you know you might agree you
might disagree well in the same issue we
had um very different perspective from
Matthew Schwarz who said like actually
um AI is evolving much much fast on a
much faster time scale than human
intelligence so very quickly AI will
understand things that and will not be
able to explain them to us and that's
fine uh we should just leave it to do
the science and we do some we'll go
fishing whether you're happy with that
or not again it's
debatable but I I think these different
perspectives highlight what I was trying
to say in the beginning is that no
matter whether computers could or should
take over in doing science in what form
I think it's important that they would
try they would have they would explain
that to us because that's what we doing
science in the beginning in the first
place and how computers or AI will uh
develop a scientific discourse again we
don't know but I do hope that it's not
the same 350 years old scientific
article so yeah that's that's what I had
to say and thank you for your
attention thanks so much Yia this
reminds me of the conversation we were
having just a couple of days ago at a
colloquium at fds what is going to count
as a discovery if we are going to have
uh machine learning sort of you know
comb through our data get trained on the
current data and simulations are we I
mean the nature of what we counts today
as Discovery is going to change
fundamentally so it's very interesting
that um but I mean do you have a
suggestion of new forms of communication
surely you don't think Tik Tok videos
are the way we should go right no
definitely definitely not but I I think
this this very work very Workshop is
very is a nice example of you know how
we communicate differently in different
fields and what we consider to be a
discovery again because um for me it was
very interesting that different ideas in
philosophy of science and which one is
correct I mean they're very beautiful
Arguments for this and for that but like
how do you decide like in your field you
know ultimately it's the experimental
validation of the observations we have
so for a lot of physics Right theory can
be as beautiful as it is if it's not
confirmed by experiment we don't care um
and in other fields like you mentioned
medical like it doesn't matter what you
find if it's not going to help me treat
a patient and in engineering it doesn't
matter if doesn't a device doesn't run
faster or consumes less so I think the
first question to ask is what do we want
from science and in different branches
of science we want different things or
we have different cost functions let's
say and from that cost function we will
Define what the discovery is and from
that the type of narrative that we want
to to use for a scientific
discourse thank you very much any other
questions Eduardo Imad and then
sham thank you I was hoping you can
comment I'm not quite following why you
feel like the discourse hasn't really
changed so I have my view is that
publication of science has changed
profoundly and I would be very curious
to see a timeline along the paradigms of
How It's become from something that
professional societies were doing to
something that is today multi-billion
Dollar corporate business so part of
that change has been and another major
change in discourse is that it used to
be the case that that you are describing
science as conveying new ideas and
observations in a persuasive and
rigorous way to his scientific peers a
ideas being maybe the introduction and
the discussion and the observations
being the results a major change has
been that in some of these Outlets there
are no methods anymore which seem to be
in my opinion I mean you really have to
dig deep and deep and deep I mean it has
changed it was easy to read the meth
methods 20 years ago before the results
now I cannot if I get the paper copy of
nature in my hands so I I I'm I'm not
following that it hasn't changed so so
there two two things so first thing you
mentioned as the business model has
changed I agree with that it's become
from like scientists like sending
letters to an editor of a scientific
Society to share that knowledge with the
peers to as you say a big a big mystes
model where people are publishing in and
companies are enabling this publishing
yeah I'm not arguing that that's the
scale of it has changed dramatically and
so does the economics of it but like if
you look at the scientific paper itself
of how it looked 50 years ago 100 years
ago and how it looks
now at the in uh in its first in this
form it's very it's very much in change
I can read the paper from a hundred
years ago and I can understand it I can
read a paper now it will have the same
sections it will have the same
presentation of results it will have yes
maybe like a lot of the complexity will
be sent into supplementary information
or in a method section but defining
feature of what we do that is science
it's the methods otherwise it's a
interesting story in the Sunday
newspaper well yes of course but what
I'm saying is the pay you know the
structur your saying right structurally
the way structurally format wise it has
not changed it's the same way you're not
sending a paper that is like a thousand
pages long that contains all the
descriptions of the entire if you look
like a you know a chadrick experiment
you can find everything he did in in 20
Pages or 50 pages and now of course you
can't do that because we're relying on
more and more information that is hidden
right is in either in supplementary
information is sending to other
references but the pure format of how
you present you have the abstract you
have the introduction of the problem you
have like the main results and that
structure has not changed at all it's
the same that it was like 50 and 100
years ago that's what I'm saying and I
feel that is restrictive and because and
that comes from the print format that
originally existed and I think that as
you said everything should be there
everything should be accessible and you
should be able to dig in deeper and
deeper and deeper with including wrong
terms right uh including wrong turns
that were made in the experiment that is
that is another big issue because we're
only reporting what it works we're never
reporting what it doesn't work which is
equally important we're also selectively
reporting right what we we're reporting
like things
that and the stories we tell are
obviously
not so what I'm trying to say the
stories we tell are very much uh shaped
by the collective experience of
scientist in um science is not in vacuum
right it's a very complex social and
economical human activity and what we're
reporting in this scientific discourse
is very much shaped by the cultural
economical and historical context right
so uh when you write when you write
write up a discovery you write it
differently depending you know what you
want to say sometimes you know it's not
it's not objective how you write a paper
it's very much what story you're trying
to get across and that story depends on
the funding you got on the journal you
publishing or what your peers think and
so on and so on it's right um and the
way we do this like weol different ways
of doing this in different outlets in
different fields um and so on so but
overall the structure has remained the
same although the complexity is much
much much bigger the the structure and
the format have remained the same
IM sorry I don't have a microphone oh
move that to will it reach
great uh okay couple of questions so the
first is in terms of like Thinking
Beyond like the PDF or Thinking Beyond
that sort of print like format um you
know are you are you looking at some of
the things that are that are being
marketed now I know like missed tools
and like sort of integrated code
interactive figures in a sort of
web-based framework these are things
that people are trying to come up with
that try to to make that jump um and I I
guess my question is a you know there's
one problem of longevity so a PDF is a
quite longevous thing you know we think
that standard will be around a while and
you can always print it out if you
create a beautiful webbased Journal that
has all of these interactive features
and can access the data underneath and
can do all of this cool stuff you know
what happens if that website shuts down
or something like that cres right yeah
data gets lost or yeah or or even just
from an economic standpoint you know
that company shuts down that the host of
that server is no longer available Etc
and then also um uh portability you know
you can download a PDF and take it
around with you and read it on your
phone or on the train or wherever so I'm
just wondering you know how much of the
the lack of perceived willingness in the
field to embrace something that is
better attuned to handling the amount of
data and complexity is due to some of
these just extremely practical kind of
things and what do we do to to address
that no you're you're absolutely right
there's uh just's a lot of um that
involved and ultimately the the role of
the primary role of the scientific
journal is to Archive knowledge if that
knowledge cannot be archived and read
100 200 years from now then it's not
very useful and print for the good or
the bad like it is readable and indeed
like the PDF we
read um Haley's paper we read Newton's
papers today and you're absolutely right
a lot of digital products are
ephemeral and that is a problem indeed
and there are lots of people who working
on how to Archive uh science and how to
keep this
knowledge and how to Port basically
these formats to the next devices and
next devices and that itself is like a
really big problem that Librarians are
looking into
the Publishers are looking into and
indeed it is difficult to solve um but
it's very much related
to how we um more like to How We Do
Science and how we preserve what we've
all the data that we have all the code
that we have and also relates a lot to
reproducibility right science and it is
very difficult question it's not and
you're right maybe one of the reason
reasons and contributing factors why the
transition is very slow it's
because it takes a while to to catch up
with these things and there there Lots
as you said there lots of tools people
have developed which are you know again
very Emeral because if the creators
leave or like there's no more funding
those tools are not available anymore
and they like in big institutions like
for example CERN they they play a big
role in the archival of data in
establishing good practices and I think
this can be done but you're right it's
it's it's one of the reasons why things
have been slow and let me thank Julia
for a great provocative
talk